a few days ago more than a dozen gunmen
some of them carrying grenades stormed a
television station in Ecuador and you
might have seen some of the dramatic
footage on social media already the
attackers delivered this message quote
we are on air so you know that you
cannot mess with the mafia and in
Ecuador that appears to be true just a
few years ago Ecuador was among the
safest countries in all of Latin America
but beginning in 20120 that began to
change and it changed very quickly from
2020 to 2022 the murder rate in Ecuador
jumped by nearly
250% again that's
250% political candidates now routinely
get shot in the street car bombings are
not uncommon just last year a leading
presidential candidate was gunned down
leaving a campaign rally what happened
to Ecuador is pretty clear it doesn't
take a foreign policy expert to figure
this out the country's ports with access
to the Pacific Ocean were taken over by
drug traffickers and cartels who rapidly
gained enormous power that's why the
majority of murders in the country take
take place in coastal towns it's also
why the presidential candidate was
targeted he promised to order the
military to secure the ports so he was
assassinated and now you can't even
watch a television broadcast in Ecuador
without seeing masked gunmen behind the
Anchor's desk now this isn't to say
eador is a simple case or one that's
directly comparable to any other country
but the Topline conclusion isn't hard to
draw and it's this when you don't defend
your country's borders chaos follows
very quickly now a lot of Institutions
that you take for granted whether
they're presidential elections or news
broadcasts uh they suddenly become
unreliable to put it
mildly things you thought were
Unthinkable uh begin to happen and
before you know it you are displaced in
your own country no matter who you voted
for the residents of Brooklyn New York
Now understand that concept very well or
at least they should because this week
James Madison High School in Brooklyn
cancelled classes so that busloads of
hundreds of illegal migrants could move
into the school during bad weather
School functions that had been planned
for months were postponed students were
told that instead of coming to class
they should log on to the internet and
learn remotely which is to say as we
know from the remote learning experiment
during Co that they won't learn anything
at all this is so hard to believe it's
so contrary to the very concept of a
Sovereign Nation that uh I I think it it
it Bears repeating New York just ordered
a public high school to displace
American students children who have
every right to be in this country in
order to house criminal foreigners who
cross the border
illegally I mean it's hard to believe
it's real but we know it's real because
the parents of students at James Madison
High School have been filming what's
happening uh
watch how does it feel that you kicked
all the kids out of school tomorrow how
does it feel do you feel good I hope you
feel good I hope you all sleep really
well tonight
hey why are you yelling at
them cuz I have a right to that's why
that's why cuz I'm an aggravated mother
that's
why yeah look at
that
look taking all of my kids
school kids out to sleep here tonight
huh how long you
staying so that's a parent watching as
the city which she funds with her tax
dollars buses in hundreds of illegal
aliens into her child's School these are
foreigners who haven't been vetted no
one has any idea who these people even
are but even if we did know exactly who
these migrants were it doesn't matter
they don't have a right to be in this
country much less in our
schools but in that footage you see the
city ushering these migrants into the
school and you can hear someone
chastising this woman for daring to be
upset about
it our children American children should
be the nation's top priority I mean
that's so obvious it shouldn't need to
be said but we are putting adult
foreigners above our own children it is
madness and they're doing this at
literal gunpoint by the way and all the
parents can do is film or they'll be
arrested and charged with with hate
crimes probably
so that's what some of them did for the
past 48 Hours parents have uh have taken
video of government agents moving
equipment into their children's high
school including CS so they can sleep in
the gym and the
hallways you may be never expected that
schools will become refugee camps in an
alleged first world country but that's
what's happening
watch oh this is Cuts this is bed
they're bringing in
food
why
not why
not I got to see where my tax dollars
are
going Hold
On by the way it's great that there are
a few parents out there who are filming
this and are expressing their outrage
but the fact that every parent isn't out
there protesting the fact that there are
only a
few is pathetic in and of
itself now there might be a reason for
some of that which is that the media
isn't talking about this you're not
going to find that footage on the
national news or even the local news we
checked with Libs of Tik Tok the account
that posted these clips and she says
that outside of Newsmax nobody has tried
to license these videos you know a few
days ago we played on the show a video
you may remember of some random female
track runner beating some random guy in
a race and that video was picked up by
dozens of outlets including the Today
Show but this story which is arguably
slightly more important than a casual
race between random college kids isn't
getting anywhere close to the it's
getting no attention I checked to see if
CNN or MSNBC or the Washington Post ran
a story on this at all and and no they
didn't cover it they didn't cover it at
all no media organizations even the ones
that claim to focus entirely on big
events in the city of New York are
tracking down the parents to hear
exactly what's happening here but Libs
of Tik Tok did and she just spoke to one
parent who's been watching all of this
with horror listen to that we don't know
what they carrying around in them
they're going to be all over that
building it's 1900 of them and another
parent was also saying that they can
come in they can stash drugs they can
stash weapons whether it's a gun or a
knife or whatever because I'm sure
you're aware there was a stabbing at
Floyd Bennett with these
migrants and they can stash these things
into school and God forbid like when the
the kids go back to school tomorrow one
of these kids find this whether it's
drugs or a weapon we were we were we
were assured that the building is going
to be completely sanitized but we're not
there and that's why it was very
disturbing to have one of the teachers
come on and say that um if you if you
parents are so concerned send your kids
in with wipes sanitizing wipes and and
and Lysol spray that's disgusting a
teacher said that at the board meeting
at the meeting at the meeting yes
wow that's like a slap in the face
yes and and she also made it seem like
why are we making a big deal about this
one day of remote learning is not going
to hurt anyone that we did it for a year
and a half apparently she's completely
missing the point here I mean I love
having my kids with me it's not the fact
that they're with us yes thank God I
have the ability to be home with my with
my child it's the principle behind
this so uh just to recap the school is
telling parents to send their students
to school with sanitizing wipes and
Lysol to clean up after the illegal
immigrants that they were forced to
abandon the school for you know just in
case the fumigation efforts aren't
sufficient so out our kids or if you are
in Brooklyn your kids are going to be
the janitors cleaning up after the
illegal
immigrants and they're telling the
parents to shut up about the whole
situation because co uh you know Co
lockdown set the precedent they did it
during
Co even though it was extraordinarily
damaging to the kids during covid and we
and everybody knows that now and
recognizes
it anybody with any sense recognize it
at the time but if you were wondering
why the left was so intent on
implementing those lockdowns well
there's your answer they wanted a
precedent they could use in the future
and already they're using it in order to
house illegal migrants in public school
now three years ago if anybody on the
right
had said that the left would use the
covid precedent to turn public schools
into homeless encampments for illegal
migrants uh they would have been called
an insane conspiracy theorist and now
here we are I mean this is a level of
civil disorder that's so extreme that
would have been so Unthinkable just a
few years ago that it defies any kind of
traditional political analysis this is
destruction that doesn't benefit any
particular political party over another
it's destruction that Cal that's
calibrated to destroy the entire
Foundation of this country and if you
don't believe that
consider the fact that just a few months
ago illegal migrants in New York City
started encroaching on the turf of the
single most reliable voting block for
the Democratic party which is black
people on welfare and these migrants
started showing up early to snag their
handouts which enraged the black
residents of New York again this is like
something out of a a sketch comedy show
it would be funny if it weren't so
tragic watch in one neighborhood in
Queens between Nicha tenants and newly
arrived migrant while tensions are
growing with not enough food to go
around why do we have to take the butt
of everything okay this community here
is already suffering the residents
living in nich's Queensbridge houses
look forward to the mobile food pantries
that show up weekly but over the past
year they have witnessed 8,000 migrants
mve to their neighborhood and they have
also noticed the migrants are also
starting to take their stuff they was
first online for the turkeys this
morning if they take tell you to be
there at 11:00 you get there like 10:30
10:45 but they already out there the
line is from over there to over here
free food giveaways especially during
the holidays have become a source of
tension between longtime New Yorkers
struggling to get by and newly arrived
migrants who are using the system to
survive a month ago one altercation got
so heated between a resident and a
migrant someone ended up in the hospital
we would never turn anyone away for a
meal but there simply just is not enough
for both Nitro residents and the migrant
shelter
residents now it's easy to say and it
makes sense to say that hey I mean you
people voted for this and you're getting
what you voted for which is
true but at the same time it should
still infuriate you no matter where it's
happening to see foreigners from another
country who don't belong here and aren't
supposed to be here legally just showing
up and taking whatever they want cutting
the line line literally in front of
actual American citizens now at this
point you might be tempted to dismiss
everything that's happening in New York
City the migrants taking over the high
schools the hotels the welfare lines as
maybe somehow an isolated incident but
it's not this this is happening in major
cities that are nowhere near the
southern border it's not just New York
that's starting to look like Ecuador
here's what Chicago's O'Hare Airport
looks like right now okay the airport
one of the biggest in the country is now
Walling off entire sections so that they
can be used as migrant encampment
just watch a few seconds of
this all right
now you uh you might see that and it
goes on and on and they they have actual
areas that are that are that are as I
said walled
off and and granted people in airports
already tend to SPL out on the ground
and treat terminals like campgrounds but
I mean this is taking that to another
level and and and nobody ever voted to
turn O'Hare International Airport into a
migrant shelter okay no politician ran
on that
platform there was no
referendum wasn't even a poll it just
happened without anybody's consent the
government is now seeding critical
infrastructure to foreigners who have no
right to be in the country pretty soon
they're not simply going to be seeding
public buildings they'll take private
property too already the government is
laying the groundwork for that and once
again Co set the president remember when
the Biden Administration banned
evictions he effectively nationalized
the rental properties the CDC took over
and decided whether people were allowed
to be evicted or not now public
officials are once again suggesting that
private property must be surrendered and
this time for the benefit of illegal
migrants just a few months ago
politicians Massachusetts in New York
demanded that residents offer up their
homes to foreign Nationals watch it is
my vision uh to take the next step to
this go to the faith-based uh locals and
then move to uh private residents uh
there are residents who are suffering
right now because of economic challenges
they have spare rooms uh they have
locals and if we can find a way to over
the 30-day Rule and other rules that
government has in in its place we can
take that $4.2 billion 4.3 it may be now
that we potentially have to spend and we
could put it back in the pockets of
everyday New Yorkers everyday houses of
Roop instead of putting in the pockets
of Corporations most importantly if you
have an extra room or Suite in your home
please consider hosting a family safe
housing and shelter is our most pressing
need become a sponsor family you can
contact the Brazilian Worker Center for
more information on how you can step up
if you're willing to have an additional
family be part of your family if you're
a local official a college President a
business owner or a faith leader with an
available building or space in your
community please work with us to offer
it as a shelter site if you're a social
service provider please consider
becoming an emergency assistant homeless
shelter provider our resources are
stretched thin there as well and if
you're a hotel or a motel owner consider
opening up for emergency assistance if
you're a landlord or a property owner we
can use you too can connect you at
service providers to help transition
families into permanent housing everyone
has something they can
offer if you're a landlord or property
owner we can use you too very
appropriately phrased isn't it we can
not even like we can use your property
we can use
you that's what they're saying in
Massachusetts they're they're not
telling these migrants to get out of the
country they're not talking about
enforcing immigration law instead
they're telling American citizens to
surrender their property this is one of
the things Americans fought the
Revolutionary War to prevent that's why
the Constitution prohibits quartering
troops in people's homes it used to be
that everybody agreed that your home was
sacrosanct Democrats don't see it that
way
anymore so what we're seeing is no
longer abstract this is no longer a
debate about illegal immigration and
open Borders or whatever what we're
seeing are illegal migrants criminals
taking over your airports and your
child's schools at this rate it won't be
too long until these criminals start
walking into television stations With
Grenades it is no longer Unthinkable for
the government to nationalize private
property to quarter these foreign
Nationals in homes and
businesses this is the inevitable
endpoint of a country that doesn't
defend its borders or enforce its laws
Ecuador and the United States are
separated by thousands of miles
trillions of dollars of GDP but they
have one thing in common which is that
criminals will take over if they are
given the opportunity
the only real difference in that respect
is that in this country unlike Ecuador
the federal government will overtly help
the criminals take control they won't
even try to hide
it and once criminals take over in this
country as in Ecuador they will not
respect the rights of children to go to
school or the rights of candidates to
run for office or the rights of
journalists to broadcast their news
reports they respect and understand only
one thing which is power and right now
all they see is
weakness and they will exploit that
weakness until one of two things happen
either every building in this country
becomes a potential migrant
encampment or every one of these
Invaders is sent back by force to
wherever they came
from hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there